[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the collider
podcast i'm collider senior editor matt
goldberg and with me is mentioning
editor adam chitwood howdy folks today
we have a special guest on the podcast
we are talking to director martin
campbell campbell has held in such films
as golden eye casino royale and the mask
of zorro his latest film is the protege
starring maggie q michael keaton and
samuel l jackson during our conversation
with campbell we talked about his work
on the pass bond films we talked about
the challenges of making the protege we
also talked a bit about green lantern
and his thoughts about that 2011
superhero film so it was a great
conversation we were so glad to have him
on the podcast i i am a huge mask of
zorro fans so this was a thrill for me
he delayed martin campbell to light it
up light it up when uh or lit up when
matt brought up the mask of zoro yes as
you maybe not maybe you can't see but
maybe you can hear it in his voice um
but it was a super candid conversation i
i super enjoyed it i also loved the
protege it's like a throwback thriller a
bit you know
it's obviously a bit of a twist on like
the atomic blonde john wick kind of
stuff
um but for me a guy who loves 90s
thrillers just like hit the sweet spot
yeah it has that great b-movie energy
that you will kind of want from that
film like i think when so many action
films are just about like
end-of-the-world stakes it's nice just
to sort of be like this is she's you
know assassin drama
in particular are great together
yeah no they're incredible and
campbell was just like game to talk
about i mean he told a great story about
the bond scene that every actor uses to
audition with when they're casting james
bond
uh you know the struggles he had in
rebooting bond with goldeneye
more struggles uh with casino royale uh
you know we talked about updating bond
for you know a new century
and then also got super candid about
green lantern uh
he just flat out said he should not have
made that movie um but i thought it was
like a very fair assessment of and also
kind of give you some insight into how
some of these blockbusters are made i
mean
you have to remember at the time that
martin campbell signed on to make green
lantern he was coming off of casino
royale he had mask of zorro he had
goldeneye and it was kind of like let me
try my hand at this and then you know as
he explains in our podcast there were a
lot of fingers in the pot and he kind of
contrasts that experience
of making a superhero movie for warner
brothers with the experience making bond
with the bond producers
so it's a really fascinating interview
not just for campbell but in you know
how some of these giant blockbusters are
made so hopefully you enjoy it hi martin
thanks for taking the time to speak with
us today not at all so i wanted to start
off by asking you you've done some great
action films in your career and i was
curious
what was it about the protege that left
out at you was it the story the the
opportunity for certain kinds of set
pieces what grabbed you about this
project
um i think probably first and foremost
the story you know most of these um
female
assassin pictures and so forth i mean uh
the action is often great look at atomic
blonde um
movies like that but the stories always
seem to be lacking and this one has a
lot of twists and turns a lot of
surprises
um
and
the relationship was the other thing
between um
uh maggie's character and michael
keaton's character and also with a her
kind of uh proxy father who was of
course sam jackson so it was a
combination of all those things really
and i hadn't done a female i don't think
i've ever done a female assassin story
so that combination is why i did it
maggie q is the best um and she's just
she's incredible in this film i was
wondering what you know once she signed
on what kind of that collaboration was
like in terms of building out that
character because it it does toe that
line between it is a female assassin
film but this is a character that has
dimensionality there's a really strong
emotional core to her story and
everything and then obviously she's
kicking tons of ass
yeah you know the the the thing about
her and the importance in this film as i
say is the relationship she's a very
good she's a terrific actress as well
you know what i mean she's
um
she's
excellent i think in the part she also
did
most of the action herself
even to that jumping off the um
you know the top of that uh
um foyer where she drops about four
floors four or five floors um on onto
the ground
she does all that herself she's extreme
well of course she was in
la femme nikita so i mean probably p i
never saw that series i i wasn't here
but
um
people seem to remember that very fondly
and how good she was um
for me
more importantly than the action was
just the relation as i say the
relationship she has between the
uh the the the two men the sam jackson
who's the father michael keaton who is
sort of
um
an assassin as well if you will
uh so you know there's an element of
pritzy's honor the john houston film i
don't know if you remember that but it
was an excellent film again with two
assassins and the relationship between
them so
can you talk a little about uh the
scenes between uh maggie and michael
because they're so they they have
fantastic chemistry and i think the film
really is electric when they're sort of
sparring together whether it's
physically or with their words yeah well
that relationship you know
sometimes you get lucky you can't sort
of
create chemistry
it depends on the actors themselves and
in this case i think it worked um
uh
i think they were very well together
they had the chemistry you know
other times when you cast
[Music]
actors in a movie or two actors the
chemistry doesn't work and
who knows what the ingredient x is if
you will but richard wenk wrote a i
thought
wrote a very interesting
kind of
he wrote a very interesting script with
those two characters
um and
it was the relationship between them
they both worked
very well together
um and uh
it just fell into place to be honest i
mean they're
both superb actors so uh
um
i i suppose we we lucked out in terms of
the chemistry between the both
well one of the things that i work so
well that i think works so well about
the film is that it's so tonally diverse
uh you know it's funny it's sexy it's
thrilling it's scary it's also really
emotional i was wondering if you could
talk about how you're modulating that
tone throughout production and making
sure each scene is hitting what it needs
to hit because again with those scenes
between maggie and michael some of those
scenes are you know laced with tension
and some of those scenes are you know
sexy and kind of exciting
well laid with tension i mean i think
the best
between them is the one in the um in the
restaurant yeah
but you know there
there's a touch of mischief about the
whole thing as well particularly from
michael keaton
who is
you know he's an extraordinary actor i
mean he's got this weird kind of um
left field kind of um
uh personality delivery and uh
always always no matter what movie he's
in is always um
really interesting you know he brings
something to the party that
very few other actors could bring um and
and really it was just sort of going
through each of the scenes getting me
certainly in the bookshop to begin with
the writing helped a lot obviously
because that kind of
uh sparring starts right from the
beginning when he walks into the
bookshop and you know is looking for
a gift and uh but the interaction
between them both
uh
was really
to a large extent i think is in the
writing and and both of them had a
very good grasp on their characters and
the sort of um
the electricity between the both you
knew this was going to go right to the
end of the movie so
um
and just really just breaking it down uh
all the scenes down getting our
rehearsals um and
just finding out um
just where we needed to be in those
scenes
you know these sort of dynamics these
the between the lead actor and the lead
actress these are sort of a recurring
thing in your films you know you've got
the great chemistry between antonio
banderas and catherine t jones and
master soro and uh between daniel craig
and eva green and casino royale is there
a particular way that you sort of you
know look for that or is that something
that you're drawn to that sort of strong
central dynamic
well you know
i guess that's down to casting the the
thing about zorro was um
catherine zesa jones again who is a
strong personality in herself i mean
she's kind of that character you see in
zorro and against banderas the boy from
across the tracks um
in the movie and what we did was that it
was in fact spielberg who recommended um
catherine zeta-jones
and i tested them i tested
three of them in mexico when i was down
there prepping
and
i put them together with antonio we did
you know we improvised some
um some scenes
and
very clearly it was um catherine who was
you know that you could tell immediately
that that was going to work in in the
case of daniel craig
with um casino royale eva green is just
i don't know if uh if you'd seen her
before casino royale but you know in her
early films her french films i had i've
looked at those apart from being
beautiful she was also a um uh
she was also a terrific actress and and
the key there
is that i think it's the only time bond
ever genuinely falls in love uh apart
from our majesty's secret service where
he gets married and
his wife is murdered by blowfelt at the
end of the movie but the essential thing
with casino was to get bond and vespa
together where bond genuinely sort of
you feel
falls in love with her that she's not
like
a lot of the body girls um you know who
a bond sort of um
gets involved with and then disposes of
um
and so that again we we did um
in fact with eva green she was very late
i think we'd started filming when we
cast her we just couldn't um
[Music]
uh
we'd tested a lot of girls
and uh
we wanted um
the producers myself
really wanted eva green
and anyway finally
they accepted her and i remember
doing tests with her on set i think it
was an m's apartment set
and doing many takes and
incredibly she lost most of her french
accent you know she
she
she lost that but she was a natural fit
for
daniel again
again a terrific actress and i i think
the thing is in casting you have to
you have to find you know whoever
in those cases the actress uh
both those actresses were terrific
maggie is terrific
and i guess it's just
down to uh to a large extent whoever you
cast um whether
the relationship is going to be
successful or not
i'm i'm fascinated by your bond films
because i think they're two of the best
in the entire franchise and you were
tasked both times with
basically restarting bond with a new
actor in the role
and going back to goldeneye i was kind
of curious you know what what was your
feeling going into that film in terms of
you have a new actor you had pierce
brosnan taking on the role but not only
that it's bond acknowledging that he's
kind of a cold war relic
in that movie
we had big discussions about that there
was in the press
there was all that thing about bond as
fast as sell by date don't forget there
was a seven year gap six or seven year
gap
where they were not allowed to make bond
films because peretti was running mgm he
was a crook
and
[Music]
you know it went into litigation and so
forth so bond was not
they were not allowed to make a bond
film from the last timothy dalton to
golden i think it was six or seven years
and we used to sit down and talk about
well how do we you know how do we get
this into the 90s and
one was
obviously casting a female m
and that was based on mi6 was being run
um
in london by a woman who was the stella
remington who was um
running mi6 at the time so that was one
thing
and the other thing we felt was that
crucial scene between m that who was
obviously played by judy dench that was
her first outing and there's that scene
between them both where she calls him a
sexist misogynist dinosaur which is true
and so in a funny way
um we talked about that scene
as answering the very question that
you're asking me now but the audience
were asking themselves you know why is
bond relevant well you know
m kicks his button basically says you
know
you're you're really something out of
the past right and you better get your
ass into gear i mean that was the that's
what we did with that and of course is a
kind of a cold war story anyway at that
time because of you know we've got the
mad general and who's
looking to um
uh
to control goldeneye and knock out all
the electronic um
you know devices all over the world so
on and so forth so um yeah i'm curious i
mean goldeneye is absolutely one of the
best bond films and i'm just curious
what your relationship was to bond when
you came into that film because it's a
film that has one foot you know in the
past in terms of the iconography but
also is forward thinking and thinking
and really i think set bond up to you
know survive throughout the 90s where
you know you had all these big effects
driven spectacle movies and you know
bond was something that as you said you
know some people felt like was a relic
from the past were you a bond aficionado
i was you know i i love bond in fact i
remember taking my mother in 1962 to see
doctor know she was an absolute
enthusiast on the books and ironically
in the books of correspond there's no
humor whatsoever and bond drinks too
much
right so he's got a dodgy liver and he's
he's he also smokes too much 70 a day
there was all of this which is in the
books if you read them and certainly in
casino royale which was his first book
in 1953 but an enthusiast absolutely i
used to go and see every bond film
probably two or three times so
i was kind of brought up with bond yeah
do you have a favorite bond film from
russia with love i think is probably my
favorite yeah that train fight is
incredible it's not just just you know
it was a contained film it was yeah it
was contained it was
um it didn't have all the flutes and
whistles and huge control rooms and
you know um
spaceships and all that nonsense it
actually was you know very contained and
uh
it was and in fact there's an
interesting ditty with this when we test
people or when we tested
um people for
casino royale they always have a scene
out of uh
they from russia with love
that they use as a a template so you
always do the scene and it's simply a
scene where bond
comes to his hotel room he opens the
door he takes off his coat right he
takes off his shoulder holster
throws it on the sofa
runs his bath senses there's someone
else in the room goes around the balcony
into his room and there's the blonde
girl from russia with love now he's got
number one
seducer but he's also going to get the
information about the um
what's it called the
code
thing that they have so it it combines
all this
you know it's how bond throws his coat
down on the
on the sofa how he takes offers
very economically and do you see what i
mean it's there was
and that's a scene that's always used as
a
um
[Music]
as a scene for all
potential bond actors who are going to
be tested having
basically rebooted the franchise with
goldeneye and then to come back and have
to reboot it again with casino royale
was that daunting to say you have to
reboot this but also do it in a
completely different way than you did
the last time we had all agreed that
the the uh goldeneye pierce had his you
know continued on
and then
i think it was as a result of the last
one film before casino
got kind of ridiculous and you know we
were skiing off um or
snowboarding off ice floes and invisible
cars and
i think there was an ice palace and all
this and to be honest the two producers
just felt
um it had gone a little too fantastic
the whole thing they got the rights to
casino royale we just had to reboot the
whole thing i went back to the book i
read the books
so
we were very much more in line with the
books and the idea was to
just put his feet on the ground make it
grittier make it tougher
right and um
and and above all
sort of keep it in in reality you know
so that that was pretty much unm and
[Music]
and to be honest i didn't really have
any difficulty with that i sort of
applauded it and loved the idea of um
rebooting it in that fashion it's also
you know a very tragic film you talk
about the love story
that the love story in casino royale i
think is is potentially the most
effective in all of the bond films um
and you see bond kind of carry that
trauma with him in the films after that
uh what how important was it to you as
you were approaching that ending of
really creating kind of a
almost like a an origin like traumatic
moment for bond that that would really
strongly affect him it was incredibly
important you know the betrayal of that
girl or who he believes betrayed him was
incredibly important because it sort of
as as you quite rightly point out it
dictates his behavior in the subsequent
movies um
and
uh really the emotional spine in that
story is for me what's the most
important in the whole movie and uh
it was essential that we got that right
a film i absolutely love is is mask zoro
and i was curious you know that phil
it's it's so much fun but also i think
it's had a real lasting impact that
other 90s action films haven't had
partially because it has such a great
sense of humor to it and i was wondering
if you've been surprised to sort of see
that kind of the film's lasting impact
in films like pirates of the caribbean
or even as recently as jungle cruise
that sort of sense of we can do these
big action scenes but also keep that
sense of humor and also a sense of
pathos really with your you know
especially when you see with anthony
hopkins character
that flowing throughout the narrative
well the sense of humor is incredibly
important and tonally it was really
important that
banderas is a terrific actor and he
understands the humor he was great at
playing that character he understood it
perfectly and catherine the same thing
both of them kind of have a big sense of
humor as um
as uh people you know it's a touch of
errol flynn in a funny way you go back
to earl flynn and watch um
michael curtis's robin hood for example
actually coates was brought on about a
third of the way through the picture
they fired the other director but the
thing is just look at the tone of those
movies right and i watched the silent
movies of zorro which again has that
tone as perhaps a little more
exaggerated but they were brilliant
films i mean they were superb
and i looked at all those and
i very much wanted it in that tone
but of course you know there's a serious
side to it as well the action i think
had to be
you know zorro has
has this ability to not only
uh fight and defeat his enemies but
uh more importantly kind of humiliate
them you know he has this wonderful way
of
embarrassing them and uh
um
[Music]
his kind of skill and everything else
that's
really what it was so tonally that all
came really from the um
from the old silent movies right a lot
of there are a lot of zorros even the
disney series which i think a lot of
people loved and
it was just really to get the tone of
the thing right and luckily i had
just terrific actors to be able to bring
that um
you know to the film
when you're dealing with a property like
that which clearly the studio hopes to
turn into a franchise was there ever
ever any pushback from the studio on on
the tone did they want it to be more
serious did they want it to be more fun
was that hard
oh it's interesting you should say that
the point was when i did that film mark
canton was at um
at columbia or i guess sony
and uh it was a film i was very
reluctant to direct i turned it down
three times before i actually agreed to
do it
and um
the the thing was that canton
was fired i think
or left
halfway through pre-production and john
kelly who i had made
goldeneye with came to take over the
studio you know we're in a rewriting
process everything else and i remember
he rang me one day and said i don't like
this project he says i don't like
you know i don't like the script i've
read i don't it's costing too much money
you know john kelly was a very funny guy
but he just used to say this very
bluntly he said i don't like it
and i said well i didn't give a damn
whether you don't like it the point is
that cancel it as you've got three days
to cancel it because i'm fed up with it
and
ten days later i heard nothing and we
were green lit
and i said to him i said to him why did
you greenlight this movie and he said
well he said i'm already in it for 12
million he inherited
endless scripts and delays and all this
crap and uh he
he said uh
you know even if it's a dog i can get 45
million
so i'm making the film for three million
dollars that was his
and then of course they come back to you
for the sequel yeah i know so you know
it was a very funny um uh um
it was a yeah
one of those
just getting the film up and running was
difficult it was
budget was tight um
a studio that didn't really want to make
it you know it had all those um
it had all of that um
[Music]
if you will that baggage on top of it
but somehow we went to mexico we made it
and you know it was uh
it turned out okay
i'm kind of curious because now we're in
sort of this landscape where a lot of
action films are superhero films and and
studios have sort of their
interconnected universes but 10 years
ago that wasn't the case and dc only had
the christopher nolan batman movies what
was it like going into green lantern was
were you sort of given sort of the
freedom to to create that world or were
there a lot of mandates saying it has to
be xyz
look you know the point about green
lantern is whereas with bond you know i
love bond i love the bond films i really
enjoyed them it was an event for me
i'm not a comic book fan i don't i i
you know and the truth is i should never
have done the film but i did because i'd
never done a comic book hero before
so
so i think the blame probably rests you
know on my shoulders to
to a large extent but it was a big
studio movie the script was not up to
par uh we had ryan reynolds terrific
obviously and blake live at least those
two got together on that movie so we we
did create something
um
the problem was i remember in the
last six to eight weeks of
pre-production every day and i mean
every day we have meetings about cutting
the budget we need to cut the budget we
need to cut the budget how are we going
to do that so every
goddamn day
and i worked out a terrific ending for
that movie and i remember i had this
quite big office down in new orleans and
at the production offices and i
plastered the walls with storyboards it
was like wallpaper everywhere these
storyboards for the ending of the movie
and uh they came in and said we can't
afford it
you just gotta cut it all you have to
come up with and so in the end you know
we came up with that or they came out
that crap ending that kind of was just
you know however you know having said
that i should never have done it i did
it
um i don't think i did a good job so
for me superhero movies there are better
people than me to be doing those movies
would you mind sharing what that ending
was that you originally planned oh
to be honest it was a huge there was a
battle in the streets right
you know in in in the streets between
the four lanterns
right i mean between our sort of heroes
right kilowog and sinestro and ryan
reynolds however that did not come to
pass so there we are we know that daniel
craig is saying that uh no time to die
will be his last outing if eon came to
you and said
you've done such a great job on the last
two reboots can you reboot it again for
us is that something that you'd want oh
yeah
i would certainly consider it because i
enjoy doing bond you know
and also the two producers are great to
work with i mean they
you're pretty much given a free hand to
you know everybody obviously
participates in the script
um
and casino i had uh paul haggis who did
a terrific job on the script
uh with the
you know who did the final draft
um
but uh
the two producers are great to work with
and um they don't interfere at all if
they think you're on the right track and
everything else they just let you get on
with it and
they support you all the way it's it's a
it's an enjoyable experience you know
well i was curious about that kind of
contrast because bond is so important
they do kind of have these uh i don't
know if there are rules but you know
there are things that they feel like
bonds should do and bond shouldn't do in
contrast to something like green lantern
where there aren't necessarily rules but
everyone has an opinion and they want to
make as much money as possible yeah and
get certain sequels i was wondering if
you felt that contrast from going from
one bond franchise to this big superhero
franchise and then if you felt
kind of a weight offer or freedom going
back to films like the protege where you
kind of felt well yeah it's true i mean
look you know bond is is is a family
affair they protect you they're great
you work bloody hard but you know you
are looked after by the
producers green lantern it's a big
lumbering studio
um
production and uh you're obviously there
are forces that you can't control you
know uh with the studio with the the um
the opinions of the studio and it's a
it's a whole different thing i never do
it again honestly um
but uh
when you get to i mean i've i've done
three
independent films i i suppose four if
you take edge of darkness but
i did the jackie chan film the foreigner
which again was independent you know
then i've done this one and i've just
finished one so
you know all three are independent
do you enjoy this do you feel that you
get the uh freedom there and sort of uh
that you don't get otherwise like with a
big studio production that allows for
more creativity yeah well first of all i
have a producer moisha dmr who is very
protective about the film or about
filming these things and uh
you do get more freedom you get more
freedom you have less politics you know
they they
in fact the one i've just done we were
completely left alone to go ahead and
just do the film and i didn't get a
phone call from them for three and a
half months that gives you an idea
how hands-on though
so you know
well this is this has been an absolute
pleasure uh thank you so much for taking
the time to speak with us congrats on
the film and uh have a have a great day
sir thanks very much indeed guys so once
again thank you to martin campbell for
taking the time to speak with us his new
film is the protege which will be in
theaters on august 20th please go check
it out if you want to keep up with this
podcast you should follow us on twitter
adam where can we find you on twitter at
adam chitwood you can find me at matt
goldberg thanks for listening everyone
and we'll be back with you next time
[Music]